we have the graph of y is equal to g of
x right over here and what i want to do
is i want to check which of these
statements are actually true and then
check them off and like always i
encourage you to pause the video and see
if you can work through this on your own
so let's look at this first statement so
this first statement says both the limit
of g of x as x approaches 6 from the
right hand side and the limit as x
approaches 6 from the left hand side of
g of x exist
all right so let's first think about the
limit of g of x as x approaches 6
from the right hand side as we approach
6 from values greater than 6.
so if we look over here we could say
okay when x is equal to 9 g of 9 is
right over there g of 8 is right over
here g of 7 is right over here looks
like it's between negative 3 and
negative 4.
g of 6.5
looks like it's a little bit
it's it's a little it's it's still
between negative 3 and negative 4 it's
but it's closer to negative 3.
g of
6.1 is even closer to negative 3. g of
6.01 is even closer to negative 3. so it
looks like the limit from the right hand
side does exist so it looks like this
one exists
now let's see and i'm just looking at it
graphically and that's that's all they
can expect you to do in an exercise like
this now let's think about the limit as
x approaches 6 from the left hand side
so i could start anywhere but let's say
when x is equal to 3
g of 3 is a little more than one
g of
4 is looks like it's a little bit less
than 2. g of 5 looks like it's close to
3. g of 5.5
looks like it's between
5 and 6.
g of
5.75
looks like it's approaching 9. and as we
get closer and closer as x gets closer
and closer to 6 from below from values
to the left of 6. it looks like we are
we're unbounded we are approaching
infinity and so technically we would say
this limit does not exist
so this one does not exist so i won't
check this one off some people will say
the limit is approaching infinity but
that technically is
infinity is not a
a value that you can say it is
approaching in the classical formal
definition of a limit so for this for
these purposes we would just say this
does not exist
now let's see they say the limit as x
approaches 6 of g of x exists well the
only way that the limit exists is if
both the left if both the left the left
and the right limits exist and they
approach the same thing
well we don't even our left limit our
our limit as x approaches 6 from the
negative side or from the left hand side
i guess i could say does not even exist
so this cannot be true so that's not
going to be true the first one's not
going to be true
g is defined at x equals 6.
so at x equals 6
it doesn't look like g is defined
looking at this graph i can't tell you
what g of 6 should be we have an open
circle over here so g of 6 is not equal
to negative 3 and this goes up to
infinity and we have a vertical
asymptote actually drawn right over here
at x equals six so g is not defined at x
equals six so i'll rule that one out
g is continuous at x equals six
well you can see that you know it goes
up to infinity then it jumps down
back down here then continues so just
when you just think about it in common
sense language it looks very
discontinuous and if you want to think
about it more formally in order for
something to be continuous the limit
needs to exist at that value
the va the function needs to be defined
at that value and the value of the
function needs to be equal to the value
of the limit and
neither of these the first two cons the
first two conditions aren't true and so
they these can't even equal each other
because neither of these exist so this
is not continuous at x equals 6. and so
the only thing i could check here is
none of the above
let's do another one of these
so the first statement both the right
hand and the left hand limit exist as x
approaches 3.
so let's think about it so x equals 3 is
what's is where we have this this little
discontinuity here this jump
discontinuity so let's approach let's go
from the positive from values larger
than three so
when x is equal to five
g of five is a little bit more negative
than negative three
g of four is between negative two and
negative three
g of three point five is getting a
little closer to negative 2
g of
3.1 it's getting even closer
closer to negative 2. g of 3.01
is even closer to negative 2. so it
looks like this limit right over here oh
i'm circling the wrong one it looks like
this limit exists and in fact it is it
looks like it is approaching
negative 2. so this right over here is
equal to negative 2. the limit of g of x
as x approaches 3 from the
right hand side and i'll think about it
from the left hand side
so we can
start let's i can start here g of
1 looks like it's a little bit
greater than negative one
g of two it's less than
one
g of two point five is between one and
two
g of two point nine looks like it's it's
a little bit less than two g of 2.99 is
getting even closer to 2. g of
2.99999 would be even closer to so it
looks like this thing right over here is
approaching 2. so both of these limits
the limit from the right and the limit
from the left exist
the limit of
g of x as x approaches 3 exists so these
are the one-sided limit this is the the
actual limit now for in order for this
to exist both the right and left-handed
limits need to exist and they need to
approach the same value well this first
this first statement we we saw that both
of these exist but they aren't
approaching the same value from the left
we are
from or sorry from the right we are
approaching
we are approaching negative 2 and from
the left we are approaching 2. so this
limit does not exist so i will not check
that out or i will not
check that box
g is defined at x equals 3.
when x equals 3 we see a solid dot right
over there and so it is indeed defined
it is indeed defined there
g is continuous at x equals 3. well in
order for g to be continuous at x equals
3
the limit must exist there it must be
defined there and the value of the
function there needs to be equal to the
value of the limit
well the function is defined there but
the limit doesn't exist there so it
cannot be continuous it cannot be
continuous there so i would cross that
out and i can't click i can't i wouldn't
click none of the above because i've
already checked something right i've
actually checked two things already